the Joe Rogan experience do you think
Peyton's gonna make it to the election
well it's gonna be a joke if he does the
idea that people are you think trying to
get on Biden I don't think if they let
the two of them talk in the same room
and have some sort of a debate I think I
think Donald Trump's gonna eviscerate
him yeah I don't know everything's gonna
be closed yeah he still has his wits
he's still sharp he still mean I know
he's still well-prepared with the digs
and how he calls him sleepy Joe I know
I'm see how dismissive he was he's a
troll but do you see how dismissive he
was when he was talking about something
that Biden said Joe the Vice President
Joe Biden said he goes first of all
Biden sent didn't say that he goes a
democratic operative said that he goes
Biden probably doesn't even know this is
happening it's funny he has these ads on
Facebook Trump that are all like anti
they're like oh he's to all the way
years are four years apart the coach
have you seen Trump's 404 pages on his
website yet oh my god there I'll show
you this is [ __ ] hilarious
he trolls everyone like when you can't
find something it's like rare page I
think stock I think that's made it into
one of our earliest episodes of dumpster
fire because we caught we have a whole
segment on the show called troll in
chief and it's basically like every week
what the [ __ ] is he doing - who's you
trolling now do you want to see the most
adorable Trump thing yeah there's a lady
who put together this that's okay oh my
god here's your's losses me that's this
404 it which Warren won - aren't you
looking for something that doesn't exist
I mean how do you come on that's this
guy understands the culture Google on
tieu to look up hashtag toddler Trump on
Instagram oh I saw this this lady made
this face swap video that's worthy of
Kyle Dunnigan
it's a Trump's face on a baby and she
starts talking to the baby accusing the
baby of doing things of the babies they
know have you seen it
right but the lady let's give the lady
credit who made it she's uh actually got
a bunch of funny [ __ ] on her Jimmy
Kimmel credits doctor fakin Stein so oh
is it
yeah okay perfect so again I don't think
this lady attributed back to you know
being the arbiter of what's on line with
the deep fakes and [ __ ] it's gonna get
so while give me some volume on this go
from the beginning Jimmy Kimmel's
talking in it oh this is the Jimmy
Kimmel one no no hashtag on Instagram go
to a toddler hashtag toddler Trump okay
it's you stuff it's adorable but it's
honestly terror also terrifying deep
fakes are terrifying they are yeah
that's it this one is particularly cute
though yeah
here I'll send you the I found it here
it is there's a penis that's it like a
miracle yes use that only 15 people have
it and it would go down close to zero
you said chloroquine would treat it you
that said bad try injecting disinfected
[Music]
China for being transporting throughout
January and
oh come on if you see it I love it
somehow first of all the ladies abusing
her baby because she's accusing the baby
or something that baby clearly doesn't
know what video the baby that they over
does video yeah stop it 100% what
happened no you don't know [ __ ] like
[Music]
you're the kind of person who believe
any gets imagine if you kid actually had
Trump's little face no like what do we
do
imagine if your kid was born and that
wasn't a real baby Pele who wasn't even
a Face Swap just people that got the kid
got a [ __ ] [ __ ] to roll the dice
kids got a seven-year-old man's face
[ __ ] do we do and you're like in a
liberal place
looks like trouble you taking him to the
supermarket he was born this way we
voted for pants I mean I like that
that's the aisle the Internet at its
best is when Syrian stuff like that
[Applause]